the first thing I learned to play was a  flam you start putting them together  getting the flam with a triplet flam  accent and it turns into a different  room you put a little which is the  double note on one hand on the flam and  that's called the cheese a lot of funny  made for percussion stuff there's always  more room for improvement especially my  SAT scores  some people come in talented but that's  not enough the more you do it the better  you'll get in it using talent and you  need hard work and practice the point of  doing it so your brain has that muscle  memory net like a second nature kind of  thing there's no better feeling than  practicing that same let's say two  measures and finally getting perfect  like finally I got it I can move on this  is this is an asan amazing I know it's  an something  you  [Music]